J'ai envie de vomir.
Il est là.
- Où ça ?
- Là-bas.
Je suis sûr que c'est lui.
- Merci beaucoup.
- Avec plaisir.
Bel atterrissage, mon pote.
Vous êtes l'équipe de tournage ?
Je suis James,
j'adore ce que vous faites.
Vous vous entendriez
avec ma mère.
Appelez-moi John.
Je suis Michelle Donovan.
Ravi de faire votre connaissance.
Bienvenue au Pérou.
J'adore votre voiture.
Ce n'est pas une voiture.
Je ne sais pas ce qu'il raconte
mais il a l'air content.
Vous avez fait bon vol ?
Oui, merci.
Parfois, ça secoue pas mal
à l'atterrissage.
Les pistes sont très accidentées
dans la région.
J'ai cru qu'elle ne lâcherait
jamais ma main.
- Ne me mets pas mal à l'aise.
- Je n'ai rien fait.
- On est là pour travailler.
- C'est ce que je fais.
- Je veux que tu te concentres.
- Je le suis.
Tu n'es pas concentré.
- Je suis en train de filmer.
- Tu vas vider la batterie.
John, comment allez-vous ?
- Laissez-moi vous aider.
- Merci.
Des lits superposés !
Tu veux le haut ou le bas ?
Les gars, venez par là.
Je vous présente les reporters.
Voici Michelle et James.
- Lui, c'est Tim.
- Salut, enchantée.
Voici Lisa.
Et lui, c'est Rob.
Rob est mon bras droit.
Quand je ne suis pas là,
référez-vous à lui.
Je sais que vous êtes venus
pour faire votre travail,
mais rappelez-vous que la mission
est notre priorité.
Il se fait tard.
Vous devriez vous installer
et dormir un peu.
Demain, on se lève tôt.
Tu dors en haut ou en bas ?
Est-ce qu'il dort déjà ?
- Déballe tes affaires.
- Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
- Je vais dormir.
- Tu vas te changer ici ?
- J'enlève ma ceinture.
- Ils vont te voir.
J'enlève juste ma ceinture,
tais-toi.
Enlève ton chapeau
et éteins cette caméra.
- Je vais aller dormir.
- Bonne nuit.
Bonne nuit, caméra.
Tout le monde est prêt ?
James, on y va.
Comment s'appellent les guides ?
Lui, c'est Carlos,
et elle, Maria.
Je ne veux pas qu'on filme
seulement la mission.
Il nous faut des paysages.
On devrait essayer
de se rapprocher de l'équipe.
- De quoi j'ai l'air ?
- T'es très bien.
Rob ?
Pouvez-vous nous en dire plus
sur cette expédition ?
Bien sûr.
On étudie l'impact
de l'intervention humaine
sur l'écosystème
et les populations locales.
On s'intéresse aussi
aux animaux en voie de disparition.
Quel est votre rôle dans l'équipe ?
Je travaille avec le Pr. Howson
depuis plusieurs années.
J'ai étudié la zoologie.
Je suis un spécialiste des primates
et des grands prédateurs.
Ce sont des espèces
qui me fascinent.
Il est bavard.
Salut, je m'appelle James.
Franco est tombé malade,
alors Steven m'a appelé.
Bref, je m'appelle James.
Chouette.
C'est génial pour vous.
C'est clair.
J'essayais de faire la conversation.
On est des professionnels.
Tu filmes ?
Tu as eu le camion ?
- Continue de filmer.
- Je filme !
Je n'y comprends rien.
On est sûrement au mauvais endroit.
On s'est trompés, non ?
On devrait peut-être
prévenir quelqu'un.
Pour quoi faire ?
Ça ne changerait rien.
L'Amazonie est menacée.
Ses magnifiques paysages
sont ravagés par la déforestation.
Qu'y a-t-il ?
C'est mieux ?
Oui.
Ne joue pas avec le micro.
- Comme ça ?
- Oui, arrête.
Cette zone vierge de l'Amazonie
est aujourd'hui menacée,
malgré son incroyable superficie
de 700 millions d'hectares.
Dans la course à la modernisation
de l'Amérique du Sud,
les compagnies privées multiplient
les contrats lucratifs.
Nombre de ces contrats menacent
la faune et la flore locale.
Ces contrats
visent à une déforestation massive
dans le but d'implanter
une agriculture de masse.
- Quelle sera la limite ?
- Attends.
Il y a quelqu'un, là-bas.
Attendez !
Qu'est-ce que vous fichez ici ?
C'est vous qui avez
coupé ces arbres ?
- J'essaie de rejoindre mon véhicule.
- Répondez-nous.
Nous venons d'appréhender
un probable représentant
d'une entreprise de déforestation.
Avez-vous une autorisation ?
Ma compagnie
n'est pas impliquée là-dedans.
- Nous travaillons en toute légalité.
- Permettez-moi d'en douter.
Avez-vous seulement pensé
aux populations locales ?
Nous aidons le gouvernement
à développer cette zone.
Nous permettons
à ces communautés rétrogrades
d'accéder au monde moderne.
- Qu'entendez-vous par rétrograde ?
- Ne vous méprenez pas.
Vous n'êtes qu'un hypocrite.
Nous ne sommes pas responsables.
Appelez donc mon bureau.
Je pense que c'est par là.
C'est bon, mon pote.
On peut trouver mieux.
Non, on continue jusque-là.
Compris ?
L'endroit qu'on devait étudier
a été détruit.
On va tenter d'accéder à un endroit
plus reculé de la forêt.
Est-ce que ça convient
à tout le monde ?
Parfait.
Attachez-vous,
les routes sont mauvaises.
Allez, on y va.
Où va-t-on ?
On part à la recherche de buissons.
Je n'aime pas trop cette situation.
Je ne devrais pas être ici.
Tim, tout va bien.
J'analyse de l'ADN
dans un laboratoire.
Je travaille avec des microscopes.
Rob ?
Vous avez déjà vu un vrai lion ?
Oui.
Vous avez vu un lion
tuer quelqu'un ?
Oui.
C'est vrai ?
Il l'a vraiment tué ?
Vous étiez présent, Pr. Howson ?
Oui, bien sûr.
- Où c'était ?
- En Afrique.
- Tom, vous êtes déjà allé au zoo ?
- Je m'appelle Tim.
James, la situation
devient gênante.
Ça vous a plu ?
- Vous me parlez ?
- Oui, vous aimez le zoo ?
Dans la forêt,
vous n'avez pas l'air à l'aise.
Je recueille des témoignages.
- Vous êtes un fan de la jungle ?
- James, s'il vous plaît.
Lisa.
Vous êtes super silencieuse.
Tout va bien ?
Ça va, merci.
- Vous avez envie de rentrer ?
- Non.
Vous avez un petit ami ?
- Vous en voulez un ?
On a heurté quelque chose.
Arrêtez-vous,
on a heurté quelque chose.
Restez dans la voiture, d'accord ?
Rob, on ne doit pas sortir
- Ça ne s'adressait pas à moi.
- C'est dangereux.
Tout va bien se passer.
- On doit vraiment sortir ?
- J'y vais.
- Qu'est-ce qu'il dit ?
- C'est la connexion.
Il fait trop sombre.
Il veut attendre demain.
On ne peut pas attendre.
C'est cassé ?
- Je sors les outils ?
- Oui.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ?
Je n'en ai aucune idée.
C'est un peu dangereux, dehors.
Je crois qu'il y a
des milices armées.
Ils ne nous enverraient pas
dans une zone dangereuse.
- Ouais, tout va bien.
- Vous dites tous ça.
J'ai vu un tas de reportages
sur ce genre d'endroit.
J'en ai vu aussi.
Dehors, il y a plein d'animaux
qui risquent de nous mordre
et de nous empoisonner.
Il y a aussi des bactéries.
Vous savez combien de bactéries
on trouve dans la jungle ?
- Vous faites peur à mon caméraman.
- Je n'ai pas peur.
On oublie la mort,
les bactéries et le poison.
Calme-toi.
Où sont mes cachets
contre la malaria ?
Les gars ?
Vous m'entendez ?
Tom, on ne sait pas
où sont tes cachets.
- Je m'appelle Tim.
- C'est ce que j'ai dit.
C'est un flingue ?
- On ne devrait pas rester là.
- Où veux-tu qu'on aille ?
Si on ne craint rien,
pourquoi il a un flingue ?
C'est sûrement par précaution.
Ça ne te rassure pas ?
On devrait en avoir aussi,
si c'est rassurant.
Arrête un peu de paniquer.
Je demande seulement
pourquoi il est armé
si cet endroit est sûr.
Il faut que tu te calmes.
Il est 1h34.
Il est 1h34 du matin.
Tout le monde dort.
On doit dormir dans la voiture
à cause d'une panne.
On pourra repartir demain.
Le Pr. Howson voulait éviter
de rouler dans le noir.
Il voulait se reposer
avant de reprendre la route.
Je ne sais pas si vous entendez.
Le bruit de la forêt
est super impressionnant.
C'est génial.
Je me demande ce qu'il y a dehors.
Il se passe un truc bizarre.
Les gars, réveillez-vous.
Ils sortent de la voiture.
On se calme.
- Qu'est-ce qu'ils font ?
- Calmez-vous.
Il se passe quelque chose.
On doit aller voir.
Vous ne sortez pas de cette voiture.
Je veux savoir ce que c'était.
Je vais voir.
- Reviens, imbécile.
- Je veux voir ce que c'est !
James, je ne plaisante pas.
Remontez dans la voiture.
- James, ça suffit.
- Remontez dans la voiture.
Je voulais voir ce que c'était.
Ça suffit.
Que se passe-t-il ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il fabrique ?
Pourquoi il s'en va ?
Il part sans nous.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'il est parti ?
Maria a laissé ses affaires,
ils vont revenir.
Je vais aller chercher son sac.
- Vous restez dans la voiture.
- C'est une mauvaise idée.
La nourriture va attirer
les prédateurs.
- J'ai peur des prédateurs.
- Alors laisse-nous faire.
Je vais sortir.
Je reviens.
Vous êtes là.
- Je pensais que vous étiez partis.
- Que s'est-il passé ?
Je ne sais pas.
- Où est allé Carlos ?
- Je ne sais pas.
Il a entendu le bruit,
et il a couru jusqu'à la voiture.
Il est parti.
Il a paniqué.
Je suis sûre qu'il va revenir.
C'est un garçon sérieux.
Il va revenir.
On dirait bien que Carlito
a levé le camp.
Tu parles de Carlos ?
- On devrait rentrer.
- C'est impossible.
On doit continuer,
on ignore ce qui se passe.
On ignore ce qui se passe
mais quoi que ce soit,
ça a terrorisé un guide expérimenté.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on reste là ?
On aime bien vous voir paniquer.
On va devoir
se débrouiller sans lui.
C'est absurde.
- On n'y arrivera pas sans lui.
- Il ne va pas revenir.
Bien sûr que si.
Tu as de l'expérience,
tu connais bien cette zone.
C'est trop loin.
Je suis désolée,
mais je ne vais pas aussi loin.
Tu ne devrais pas
gaspiller la batterie.
Je ne gaspille pas la batterie,
je travaille.
Ça n'a rien de drôle.
Tu n'écoutes rien.
Il est parti, on n'a pas le choix.
Maria accepte de nous accompagner
en attendant Carlos.
- Il est parti avec le matériel.
- Effectivement.
On peut s'en sortir
avec ce qu'il reste.
On peut mener
une bonne partie de l'étude.
C'est loin d'être idéal,
mais ce sont les risques du métier.
Il ne plaisantait pas
en disant que c'était isolé.
Michelle ?
- Faites attention au chemin.
- Continue de filmer.
- Il n'y a pas un autre chemin ?
- Tim, ne recommence pas.
Essaie de voir ça
comme une aventure.
Une aventure ?
C'est une bonne idée.
C'est rentré dans ma bouche !
Bienvenue dans la jungle.
Reste derrière
pour filmer notre avancée.
Donne-moi une seconde.
Attends !
Donne-moi ton sac et filme,
c'est un super plan.
Les gars, tenez le rythme.
Ne soyez pas à la traîne.
Vous n'avez pas compris ?
Je vous ai demandé d'avancer.
Ne vous arrêtez pas
pour vos prises de vue.
Vous nous mettez tous en danger.
Le centre de recherche
veut ces prises de vue.
Si ça ne vous convient pas,
je peux les appeler.
Il n'y a pas de réseau,
et il est trop tard
pour faire demi-tour.
Ne vous sentez pas obligé
de nous materner.
Il y a un serpent.
Salut, mon pote.
Regarde-moi.
- Steve t'a parlé du livre ?
- Tu es obsédé par Steve.
Il me comprend.
Son livre s'appelle
Les Secrets de l'évolution.
- C'est la base de la cryptozoologie.
- Crypto-quoi ?
Zoologie.
- Tu viens de l'inventer.
- Pas du tout.
Ça parle des animaux
qu'on ne connaît pas encore.
Bien sûr.
Le monstre du Loch Ness,
par exemple.
Ce type est un précurseur.
- Tu parles sérieusement ?
- Bien sûr.
On devrait lui parler
de ce qui se passe ici.
Ecoute
Tu as lu le briefing,
tu sais pourquoi on est là.
Contente-toi de filmer,
si tu en es capable.
Laisse-moi parler.
- Tu es une vraie garce.
- Pardon ?
Rien, tout va bien.
Regardez ce magnifique motif.
Je peux vous poser
quelques questions ?
- Vous avez trouvé un serpent.
- Oui, effectivement.
- C'est une couleuvre tachetée.
- Elle pique ?
Non, mais on dirait
qu'elle est venimeuse.
Sa couleur est un leurre.
Elle lui sert à dissuader
les animaux de vouloir la manger.
Il existe un serpent venimeux
qui lui ressemble beaucoup.
Pour les différencier,
il existe un dicton qui dit
"Rouge sur noir, il y a de l'espoir,
mais jaune sur rouge,
il vaut mieux que tu bouges."
Racontez-nous un peu
ce que vous faites ici.
D'accord.
Que voulez-vous savoir ?
Qu'est-ce que vous faites ici ?
Pourquoi avez-vous choisi...
Qu'avez-vous dans la main ?
- Un pot à échantillon.
- Parlez-nous-en.
- Que je vous en parle ?
- Dites-nous ce qu'il contient.
De la mousse.
Il contient de la mousse.
Avant la naissance de l'Humanité,
toute la planète était comme ça.
Ces endroits se font rares,
profitez-en.
Regardez, il y a un crocodile.
Ne vous approchez pas.
On pourrait se filmer
près de la chute.
- Oui, tout devant.
- Ça va être génial.
Ne vous approchez pas du bord.
- Tout va bien ?
- Oui, c'est un problème technique.
Je ne veux pas nager
avec les crocodiles.
- Venez, James.
- C'est hors de question.
- Je ne suis pas d'accord.
- Ça va aller.
C'est pas vrai.
Il est sur mon visage, Professeur.
Professeur,
il grimpe sur mon visage.
- Professeur !
- Calmez-vous, tout va bien.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
- C'est une petite bête.
- Elle est énorme !
Elle est inoffensive,
arrêtez de paniquer.
Elle était sur mon visage.
- C'était génial.
- Regardez-la.
Ne vous approchez pas.
- C'est un insecte plutôt sympa.
- Ne vous approchez pas.
Vous ne craignez rien.
Tom évolue dans son milieu.
Il ignore tout du monde extérieur.
Tu veux bien m'aider ?
Oui, attends une minute.
Je documente le travail
des abeilles ouvrières
qui montent leur campement du jour.
Bonjour, Professeur.
C'est bon, d'accord.
Voici donc notre magnifique feu.
Tom et le professeur se tiennent
juste à côté.
Il y a aussi Robby et Maria.
Pose cette caméra et mange.
Je partage cette tente avec Rob.
Tim et Lisa, vous dormez là.
L'équipe tournage, là-bas.
On se mélange ?
Non, on va rester comme ça.
C'est mieux.
- Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
- Tu as entendu ?
Je n'ai rien entendu,
rends-moi la caméra.
Ne l'éteins pas.
Tu n'entends pas ?
- De quoi tu parles ?
- La ferme.
Ça l'a encore fait.
- C'était quoi ?
- La ferme, tais-toi.
Écoute.
Ok ! Qu'est-ce q...
Rallume la lumière.
C'est mieux comme ça ?
Ça fait peur
- J'ai la trouille.
- Moi aussi, ça se rapproche.
- Tu le vois ?
- Je vais ouvrir.
Arrête, t'es complètement dingue !
- Je pensais que tu voulais voir.
- Surtout pas.
- Il est juste là.
- Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
J'en sais rien.
- On fait quoi ?
- Tais-toi !
On dirait qu'il s'en va.
Merde !
C'est quoi, ce truc ?
- C'est peut-être un sanglier.
- Je ne sais pas.
Le professeur a dit
qu'il y avait des jaguars.
Il a dit qu'il y avait des jaguars,
c'en est peut-être un.
On dirait un bruit de lion.
Il n'y a pas de lion
dans la forêt amazonienne.
- Je vais tomber.
- Tim, prends ton temps.
Mets ta main ici.
- Cette nuit ?
- Oui, c'était un gros animal.
- Vous l'avez vu ?
- Non.
De nuit, tout paraît
plus impressionnant.
C'était sûrement un animal étonné
de nous trouver là.
Il était vraiment très proche.
Il se collait à la tente.
Mettez-vous à sa place.
Il n'a jamais vu d'humain,
vous avez dû l'intriguer.
Pensez un peu à ces insectes.
On ne les connaît pas,
alors on veut s'en approcher.
Pourtant, on ignore
s'ils sont dangereux.
Ils pourraient très bien
être plus venimeux qu'un cobra,
et on s'en approche quand même.
Quel que soit l'animal
que vous avez entendu,
s'il avait voulu vous faire du mal,
il l'aurait fait.
On devrait interviewer Maria.
- Quoi ?
- Éteins la caméra.
- Regarde-la.
- Arrête.
Elle a l'air ailleurs.
- Elle est fatiguée.
- Elle a l'air possédée.
En tant que guide,
pourriez-vous nous en dire plus
sur l'animal
qui a approché le campement ?
Avez-vous vu ou entendu
quelque chose ?
- Non.
- Vous l'avez forcément entendu.
Je ne veux pas en parler.
Dites-nous ce que c'était.
On a tous très peur.
Vous ne voulez pas savoir
ce que c'était.
- Ne touchez pas la caméra.
- Que se passe-t-il ?
Il se passe des choses
que vous ne comprendriez pas.
Vous êtes irrespectueux
envers la forêt.
Si vous ne respectez pas la forêt
elle vous dévorera.
Si vous voulez survivre,
souvenez-vous-en.
On se calme,
tout le monde baisse d'un ton.
Je te promets
que nous vouons tous
le plus grand respect à cet endroit.
Essaie de te calmer.
Je veux savoir quel animal c'était.
On finira par trouver.
J'analyserai les traces
quand on sera de retour.
En attendant, détendez-vous.
Vous ne nous facilitez
pas la tâche.
Je te l'avais dit,
il y a un truc qui cloche.
C'est bizarre qu'elle pète un câble.
Écoutez, ne vous en faites pas.
Les gens du coin sont superstitieux.
Soyez un peu plus respectueux.
- J'aurais dû mieux me renseigner.
- Ne vous en faites pas.
N'oubliez pas votre sac.
- Faites gaffe !
- Désolé.
Faites attention
où vous mettez les pieds.
D'accord.
Abruti.
Deuxième jour d'expédition.
En fait, c'est le quatrième.
Deuxième jour d'expédition,
voici le rapport du jour.
Il s'est passé
des trucs incroyables.
Le guide s'est tiré
au milieu de la nuit,
on n'en revenait pas.
James ?
Tu parles tout seul ?
Non.
Oui, je parle tout seul.
- T'as pu chier ?
- Non, toujours pas.
Moi non plus,
je me sens un peu ballonné.
Ça fait combien de temps que tu...
On devrait rejoindre les autres.
Michelle, attends-moi.
Tu ne devrais pas y aller
D'où vient ce sang, Professeur ?
Je ne sais pas.
Ça pourrait être un fourmilier
ou un primate.
Ou peut-être un capybara.
On devrait pouvoir
identifier le prédateur.
C'était sûrement un jaguar,
ils savent grimper partout.
Ça ne serait pas étonnant.
Essayons de trouver la proie.
Il n'y a pas beaucoup de sang.
Allons voir par là.
Prenez votre temps.
Soyez attentifs,
la proie peut être n'importe où.
Il y a du sang ici aussi.
Viens voir, Tim.
N'aie pas peur.
- Viens prendre une photo.
- Allez-y, Tim.
Enlève ton sac, tu vas tomber.
Ce serait génial
que le jaguar soit toujours là.
Rob, vous feriez quoi
si le jaguar était là?
Il pourrait surgir et bouffer Tim.
Allez-y, Tim !
- Approche-toi doucement.
- Ça pue.
Récupère tout ce que tu peux.
- C'est répugnant.
- Tu t'en sors bien.
Continue comme ça.
Il nous en faut beaucoup ?
Ramasses-en encore un peu.
Voilà, c'est parfait.
C'est bon.
Parfait.
Ça va, James ?
Vous avez l'air bizarre.
Rob, les scorpions
pondent-ils des oeufs ?
Pourquoi tu ne crois pas
aux monstres ?
- Je devrais ?
- Pourquoi pas ?
C'est excitant de penser
qu'ils sont tout près.
- Ils n'existent pas.
- Tu en es sûre ?
C'est scientifique.
La science a d'abord affirmé
que la Terre était plate
et que le Soleil en faisait le tour.
Aujourd'hui,
on croit ce que l'on voit.
Ce n'est qu'un proverbe.
Prenons un exemple.
- As-tu déjà vu une raie ?
- Oui.
- C'est vrai ?
- Oui, lors d'un voyage.
- As-tu déjà vu un éléphant de mer ?
- Oui.
- Vraiment ?
- Oui, lors du même voyage.
Où tu pars en voyage, toi ?
- As-tu déjà vu une baleine ?
- Je sais à quoi tu joues.
As-tu déjà vu une vraie baleine
de tes propres yeux ?
Non.
Comment sais-tu
qu'elles existent ?
C'est comme pour Dieu.
Personne n'a vu Dieu,
mais des gens ont vu des baleines.
S'il te plaît.
Il faut que tu te concentres.
Je sais que tu tiens
à ton crypto-truc,
mais ce reportage
est fondamental pour moi.
- Je n'y arriverai pas sans toi.
- D'accord.
- Les monstres existent vraiment.
- C'est faux.
Tu n'en sais rien.
C'est faux.
Ça suffit.
Merci.
C'est bon, je la tiens.
C'était génial.
C'est trop marrant.
J'arrive.
Je vous aide, Lisa ?
Elle est froide.
Bien joué, Professeur.
Allez, les gars.
On continue.
Regardez ça.
C'est incroyable.
Salut, bonhomme.
Tu veux des bananes ?
- Je dois regarder de plus près.
- C'est quoi ?
Je n'en suis pas très sûre.
Vous êtes censé être une experte.
- Qu'avez-vous trouvé ?
- Seigneur, il est immense.
Voyons voir.
Tiens.
Nous avons trouvé
un boa constricteur.
Les boas ressemblent beaucoup
aux pythons.
Généralement, ils ne vivent pas
dans cette région.
Cette espèce pourrait éventuellement
avoir été importée
par une action humaine.
Elle pourrait aussi confirmer
l'émergence de nouvelles espèces.
C'est précisément l'objet
de notre recherche.
Ce serait exceptionnel.
Sois sage, mon grand.
On veut seulement te regarder.
- Regarde la caméra.
- C'est incroyable.
Un de nos chercheurs
vient de trouver cette petite bête.
Il se prélassait au soleil,
pour essayer de se réchauffer.
Les serpents ont le sang froid.
Ils recherchent la chaleur
pour mieux digérer leurs proies.
Regardez-le.
Il s'est enroulé autour de ma jambe.
Tout va bien.
Viens par là, mon pote.
Ne t'approche pas de mon visage.
Je ne veux pas te servir de repas.
Il ne doit pas avoir
plus d'un ou deux ans.
Il est magnifique.
Il pourrait être
la raison de notre voyage.
A-t-on un sac assez grand pour lui ?
Les serpents sont extrêmement
intelligents.
Je vais le décrocher.
- Attention à sa tête.
- Je vais le tenir.
C'est une découverte incroyable
pour l'équipe.
Je savais qu'on trouverait
quelque chose.
- Maria, tu connaissais ce serpent ?
- Non.
- C'est du beau travail.
- Ouais, c'est génial.
On va pouvoir rentrer
étudier nos échantillons.
- Le laboratoire nous attend.
- Tu veux déjà rentrer ?
On a trouvé ce qu'on cherchait.
On a notre nouvelle espèce,
on peut rentrer.
On ne peut pas rentrer,
on doit continuer les recherches.
Qui sait ce que réserve
encore la forêt ?
L'aventure vient à peine
de commencer.
Le temps file,
il faut qu'on continue.
- L'Amazonie révèle ses trésors.
- C'était dingue.
- Ce serpent était colossal.
- Tu m'écoutes ?
- Est-ce que tu réalises ?
- Tu ne m'écoutes pas.
Il aurait pu nous mordre.
Ça aurait été génial.
Bien joué, Professeur.
Tu as eu peur.
Je ne pensais pas que ce voyage
serait une source d'inspiration.
C'est splendide.
Aujourd'hui,
les gens pensent avoir tout vu.
C'est tellement fascinant
que j'en perds mes mots.
En Amazonie, une nouvelle espèce
est découverte tous les trois jours.
On en a trouvé une,
qui découvrira les autres ?
Ce sont seulement des statistiques.
On a fait tout ce chemin,
et vous étudiez les cailloux.
Imaginez tout ce qui nous entoure !
J'imagine.
Salut, Lisa.
Je vous en supplie, ne me dites pas
que vous récoltez des cailloux.
Non, pas du tout.
J'observe des bryophytes.
Génial, que sont les brio-filtres ?
"Bryophytes",
c'est de la mousse.
De la mousse ?
À un niveau basique, la mousse
peut affecter tout un écosystème.
Si on ne la contrôle pas,
elle peut devenir très dangereuse.
Il paraît que la mousse
a déclenché l'âge de glace.
Vous saviez qu'un gars
a cloné un mammouth ?
Pardon ?
On était en train
de parler de mousse.
Vous avez dit "âge de glace".
Je me demande
s'il a trouvé son gland.
- Revenons à la mousse.
- Les gars !
Où est Tim ?
Il était là.
- Les jaguars sentent la peur.
- Que fais-tu ?
- Je veux le faire sortir.
- On ne joue pas à cache-cache.
Il y a des prédateurs dans le coin,
arrêtez de crier.
- Il est sûrement tout près.
- Capitaine Courage a-t-il fui ?
Il est facile de se perdre
dans la jungle.
- Écoutez.
- Je l'ai trouvé !
C'est Lisa.
Rob dit qu'il ne faut pas
hurler dans la jungle !
Que fais-tu ?
Je ne peux pas descendre
avec la caméra.
Pose-la et fais attention.
- Lisa, écarte-toi.
- Éloignez la caméra.
Tim, regarde-moi.
- T'es contente ?
- Je n'ai rien fait.
Il va bien ?
Arrête de filmer.
Doucement.
Je vais regarder ton épaule.
Tu t'en sors bien.
- C'est horrible.
- Qu'est-ce qui est horrible ?
Rien, tout va bien se passer.
Elle n'est pas cassée.
Il s'est disloqué l'épaule,
je vais la remettre en place.
Fais vite pour ne pas
abîmer ses ligaments.
- Vous allez m'abandonner ?
- Bien sûr que non.
On va remettre ton épaule en place,
sois courageux.
Je veux que tu mordes ce bâton
le plus fort possible.
Mords-le très fort.
On va compter jusqu'à trois.
- Que se passe-t-il à trois ?
- Un, deux...
Je suis fier de toi.
Tu entends ?
Je sais que c'est douloureux.
- Ça va aller.
- Tenez bon, Tim.
Tout va bien.
Ça va passer.
On aurait pu ne pas te retrouver.
Je voulais découvrir un truc rare,
moi aussi.
Lisa avait raison.
C'est l'aventure.
Qu'avez-vous trouvé ?
Rien.
Allez, on y va.
Il faut qu'on avance.
C'est parti.
Merci, Professeur.
Pourquoi tu ne dis plus rien ?
Pour rien.
- Tu es fâchée ?
- Non.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
- Tu as été dur avec Tim.
- Pardon ?
C'était pour rire,
je fais toujours des blagues.
C'est bien là le problème,
tu ne prends jamais rien au sérieux.
Au moins, moi, j'ai lu les notes.
Tu sous-entends
que je ne les ai pas lues ?
Tu n'es que le caméraman.
Je ne suis que le caméraman ?
Tu n'as rien fait
depuis qu'on est arrivés.
Tu plaisantes ?
Je m'excuse.
Pouvons-nous vous interviewer ?
Professeur ?
- Ce n'est vraiment pas le moment.
- Ce ne sera pas long.
Nous avons vraiment besoin
de ces renseignements.
Professeur, s'il vous plaît.
Pouvez-vous m'expliquer
ce que vous êtes en train de faire ?
Non.
Il n'y a pas de lion
en Amérique du Sud.
Ils vivent plutôt en Afrique.
Il n'y a pas de lion.
Vous êtes en sécurité.
Quand j'étais petit,
j'ai vu un groupe de Masaïs
se faire poursuivre par des lions.
Ils n'avaient pas de voiture,
ni de bâtiment où se réfugier.
Ils avaient seulement des bâtons
pour se protéger.
Ils ont placé ces bâtons
au-dessus de leur tête.
Ils se sont dirigés vers les lions.
Ils essayaient de se faire
plus menaçants qu'eux.
Les lions
les regardaient s'approcher,
et les Masaïs
continuaient d'avancer.
Après quelques minutes,
ces grands et puissants prédateurs
ont fini par faire demi-tour.
La différence
entre un prédateur et une proie,
c'est qu'il y en a un qui chasse
et un qui prend la fuite.
Si je croise un lion, je m'enfuis.
Ce serait une grande découverte
si vous en voyiez un ici.
- Le feu de camp vous plaît ?
- Oui.
C'est agréable.
Ça va, Tim ?
Ça va aller.
Je pue, ou quoi ?
Rob ?
Robby ?
Roberto.
Votre prise de karaté
pour sauver Tim était géniale.
Merci.
Michelle ?
Tu as envie d'une prise de karaté ?
Elle est fatiguée.
Demain, on se lève tôt.
Allez vous reposer.
- Laisse-moi t'aider.
- Merci.
Tu es prêt ?
Bonne nuit, Tom.
Tim, pardon.
Vous aussi, James.
Reposez-vous.
Oubliez les empreintes,
on s'en occupera plus tard.
Je les étudierai demain matin.
Fais-le, personne ne va
te mordre les fesses.
C'est quoi, ce truc ?
C'est ça, fiche le camp !
Insectoïde
- Je peux rentrer ?
- Non, attends.
C'est bon.
Faites de beaux rêves !
Je ne sais pas si vous entendez.
Je crois que...
Il y a un truc dehors.
- Quelqu'un d'autre est réveillé ?
- Je ne crois pas.
Il rôde dans le camp
depuis un moment.
- Tu as vu ce que c'était ?
- Non.
Je ne sais pas ce que c'est,
mais c'est énorme.
C'est la même bête qu'hier ?
Elle est partie ?
Rob ?
Courrez !
On se casse, courrez !
Ne vous arrêtez pas.
- Éteins la lumière.
- D'accord.
- Attrape ma main.
- C'était quoi ?
Je n'en sais rien.
- Il nous suit ?
- Je ne sais pas.
On va mourir.
Mon Dieu, il revient.
- Je vais allumer la lumière.
- Ne fais pas ça.
- Bon sang, Tim.
- Où sont les autres ?
On a couru.
Il l'a attaquée, et on a couru.
Qui a-t-il attaqué?
- Tu n'as rien vu ?
- Non, je me suis mis à courir.
Lisa.
Où est-elle ?
Elle est partie.
Il faut la trouver.
Tu ne comprends pas.
Elle est morte.
- C'est impossible.
- Je suis désolée.
On a vu toute la scène.
Je suis désolée.
Il faut qu'on bouge.
Je vais éteindre la lumière.
Ne vous arrêtez pas.
Ça va aller.
James, dégagez !
Rob !
Cours, cours !
Si quelqu'un voit cette vidéo,
notre camp a été attaqué.
Une sorte de dinosaure
nous a attaqués.
J'ai perdu le reste de l'équipe.
Ils sont peut-être morts.
Je crois qu'il ne reste que moi.
Il y a quelqu'un ?
Michelle ?
Qui est là ?
Tu es là ?
Michelle, est-ce que ça va ?
On ne peut pas rester là.
Où veux-tu qu'on aille ?
Je ne sais pas.
On ne peut pas rester là.
Il nous faut un endroit en hauteur.
Il faut qu'on prenne de la hauteur.
Éteins la caméra, s'il te plaît.
- Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
- C'est un avion.
Il faut qu'on s'approche.
- Non, attends.
- Quoi ?
Il faut trouver un endroit surélevé.
On est assez haut ?
On est d'avantage en sécurité,
maintenant.
- Il va nous trouver.
- Non.
Ne t'inquiète pas.
On va s'en sortir,
il suffit d'être prudents.
On va avancer petit à petit.
- Tu veux de l'aide ?
- C'est bon.
Je te tiens.
Regarde autour de toi
et prends ton temps.
Ne t'inquiète pas, tout va bien.
- C'est haut.
- C'est ce qu'il nous faut.
Je n'y vois rien.
- Tu vois où tu en es ?
- Non.
Il y a un gros rocher près de toi,
mets ton pied dessus.
Fais attention.
Vas-y doucement.
Tout va bien, je suis derrière toi.
Continue, je te suis.
- Je suis là.
- Laisse-moi t'aider.
On y est.
Ça va ?
Ça va aller.
On est en sécurité.
C'est quoi, ce truc ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il fait là ?
- Quelqu'un est-il au courant ?
- Je n'en sais rien.
Tu as lu des choses sur le sujet.
Tu t'y connais en monstres.
Ça va ?
Oui.
Tu as dormi ?
Ne bouge pas.
Désolée.
- Il nous a entendus ?
- Je pense que oui.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
On dirait un dinosaure.
- C'est impossible.
- Pourtant, il est là.
Je ne comprends rien.
On ne maîtrise pas l'évolution.
On ne peut pas
rationaliser la nature.
On ne peut pas l'étudier.
Ne bouge pas.
J'y crois pas.
C'est Maria.
Il mange Maria.
On devrait essayer de descendre.
Tu es devenu fou ?
Si on reste là,
il va nous trouver.
Il faut qu'on se tire
pendant qu'il est occupé.
Occupé ?
Il mange Maria.
Tu tiens vraiment à la rejoindre ?
Je sais que la situation
n'est pas idéale.
- Ils sont plusieurs.
- Tu plaisantes ?
- Il faut qu'on bouge.
- Tu disais qu'on était en sécurité.
Suis-moi.
Ne tombe pas.
Je te tiens.
Descends doucement par là.
Par là.
Va sur la droite.
Ne bouge plus.
On va rester là un moment.
Ne fais aucun bruit.
Tout va bien,
il ne peut pas nous voir.
Il s'est tiré.
C'est bon, il est parti.
Écoute-moi, on va partir
dans la direction opposée.
Suis-moi sans faire de bruit.
Où va-t-on ?
On retourne au campement.
On doit retrouver le campement.
Laisse-moi reprendre mon souffle.
Il faut qu'on retrouve notre chemin.
J'en ai marre.
C'est pas vrai.
Regarde ça.
Vous êtes vivants.
T'es dingue de surgir comme ça.
- Tu as failli me tuer.
- Pardon.
Je ne voulais pas faire de bruit.
- Ça va ?
- Pas vraiment, non.
Tu as vu les autres ?
Vous courriez trop vite,
je vous ai perdus.
Ensuite, j'ai pensé
que vous m'aviez abandonné.
- On va fouiller le camp.
- Tu cherches de la nourriture ?
On devrait plutôt se tirer d'ici.
Il n'y a personne.
Non.
Ils doivent être quelque part.
- Il y a quelqu'un ?
- Tais-toi.
On va fouiller les tentes.
Il n'y a personne.
- On doit continuer à chercher.
- James, calme-toi.
Il n'y a personne d'autre.
C'est impossible.
Il est vivant.
Professeur, tout va bien ?
Vous êtes vivant.
Quel est le plan ?
- Il ne reste que vous ?
- Oui.
Vous l'avez vu ?
Où est Rob ?
Il ne s'en est pas sorti ?
Et Lisa ?
- Elle n'a pas survécu.
- On n'a rien pu faire.
Vous n'avez pas essayé.
- Tu as été le premier à t'enfuir.
- J'ai eu peur.
Ça suffit.
La seule chose qui compte
est de sortir d'ici.
On doit à tout prix rester soudés.
Il en va de notre survie,
c'est compris ?
Vous l'avez vu ?
- Il faisait sombre.
- Il était énorme.
Vous avez des images ?
On peut regarder.
Professeur, qu'avez-vous vu ?
- Je ne sais pas.
- Je pense que si.
- C'était un dinosaure.
- C'est impossible.
Professeur ?
Vos théories étaient correctes.
Quelles théories ?
- Vous étiez au courant ?
- J'ignore tout d'eux.
C'est peut-être une espèce
qui a évolué.
- Il existe plein de possibilités.
- Vous aviez raison.
Cette vidéo peut changer le monde.
Les gens refuseront d'y croire.
Ils sont morts,
et ce truc est toujours en liberté.
On doit retourner à la civilisation.
Et que fait-on des corps ?
On doit les enterrer.
Cette créature va revenir.
Je veux partir immédiatement.
On ne peut pas prendre le temps
de les enterrer.
Si on meurt, qui nous enterrera ?
On ne peut pas les abandonner.
Si vous voulez les honorer,
contentez-vous de rester en vie.
Récupérez vos affaires,
on s'en va.
On y va.
Ne touchez à rien.
Ils vont sentir notre odeur.
Ne bougez plus.
Pourquoi on s'arrête ?
Je pense qu'il y a quelque chose
dans ces arbres.
Allez, on continue.
- Ça va aller.
- Écoutez-moi.
On va remonter la rivière
en direction des villages.
C'est notre seule chance
de s'en sortir.
Si ce dinosaure...
Si cette créature arrive par là,
il faut à tout prix la devancer.
Un dinosaure ?
Tu es un scientifique,
tu sais qu'ils ont pu survivre.
Une population reproductrice
peut avoir évolué ou muté.
Quelqu'un les aurait vus.
Des satellites filment en permanence
chaque recoin de la planète.
Ce sont des suppositions.
Je doute que des satellites
surveillent la forêt amazonienne.
C'est impossible.
Vous les avez vus
de vos propres yeux.
Ils sont différents.
Ils sont plus petits
et plus intelligents.
J'ignore comment,
mais ils ont survécu.
Professeur
La caméra d'abord.
Attendez ici.
- Passez-moi le sac.
- Non, c'est bon.
- Je vais le porter un peu.
- Vous êtes sûr ?
Ça vous soulagera.
On doit trouver un chemin.
On va tenter par là.
C'est bien, continue.
Tout va bien, Professeur ?
- Tu devrais manger.
- Passe-moi la barre de céréales.
Il va falloir partager.
Il n'en reste qu'une.
Ça va ?
Il va bien ?
Vous voulez manger ?
Non, merci.
Il est bizarre.
Il faut qu'on parte.
Arrêtez-vous.
Vous le voyez ?
Il est là.
Je le vois.
Ne bougez pas, d'accord ?
Restez groupés.
Que faites-vous ?
Vous êtes dingue,
il faut partir dans l'autre sens.
- Je veux le voir.
- Vous allez nous faire tuer.
Il sait ce qu'il fait.
On n'est pas en Afrique.
C'est n'importe quoi.
Pourquoi il ne bouge plus ?
Allez vous-en !
- On ne peut pas le laisser.
- Il nous a dit de partir.
Plus vite !
Allez ! Allez ! Allez !
J'arrive
Je suis juste là
Il faut qu'on remonte la rivière.
Les gars
James, on est là.
- Tout va bien ?
- Ça va aller.
Tu saignes.
- On doit continuer.
- Non, attends.
Reste assise.
- Qu'est-ce que tu as fait ?
- J'ai trébuché.
Soulève ton tee-shirt,
je dois regarder.
Soulève ton tee-shirt.
D'accord, c'est plutôt profond.
Passe-moi de la gaze.
Écoute-moi bien.
Je vais mettre de la gaze
sur ta blessure.
Il faut arrêter le saignement.
La gaze va ralentir le saignement.
Soulève ton tee-shirt.
Ça risque de faire mal.
Tu vas être très courageuse
et ne faire aucun bruit.
Il va falloir que tu te penches
pour que je fasse le bandage.
C'est presque fini.
On y est presque.
Il n'y avait rien
à l'intérieur de la plaie, si ?
Je ne sais pas,
mais on doit partir.
Il faut attacher le bandage.
Ils arrivent, je les entends.
Vas-y doucement.
Ce sont seulement
des carcasses d'animaux.
Ne t'arrête pas.
Avancez !
Ne vous arrêtez pas,
il faut qu'on avance.
Continuez à monter.
Ne bougez pas.
Sa vision est basée
sur le mouvement.
Si on ne bouge pas,
il ne nous verra pas.
Avance.
Ne te retourne pas.
Continue d'avancer.
Attends.
Avance, ne te retourne pas.
On continue, ne t'arrête pas.
Je vais bien !
Prends la caméra.
- On se fiche de la caméra !
- Je vais bien.
- Avance.
- Je n'en peux plus.
Ça marche.
Je l'ai réparée.
C'est bien, James.
Ça va ?
Non.
Tu as failli mourir
pour récupérer la caméra.
Je ne pouvais pas
la laisser couler.
Ces images
sont bien trop importantes.
Tu comprends ?
C'est beaucoup trop important.
Ces images vont révolutionner
la science.
Elles vont chambouler
les théories de l'évolution.
Ce sont des preuves.
Les gens doivent les voir.
Rien de ce qui se trouve
sur cette caméra
ne justifie que tu aies
risqué ta vie.
Bien sûr que si.
Ces vidéos sont fondamentales.
Tout le monde doit les voir.
On a découvert un truc incroyable.
Éteins la lumière.
Je t'en supplie.
Je vais l'éteindre.
Leur vision ne doit pas
être basée sur le mouvement.
On est perdus.
On va retrouver notre chemin
en suivant le bruit de l'eau.
Il ne nous a pas vus.
Attends une minute.
Il faut que je le filme.
Si je ne le filme pas,
ils seront tous morts en vain.
Je dois le faire,
ne bouge surtout pas.
Il y a quelque chose
dans le buisson.
On bouge d'ici.
Suis moi !
Ok ?
Où ?
On ne doit plus s'arrêter.
Tout ce qui compte,
c'est d'avancer.
Je ne comprends pas
Dirige-toi vers la grotte.
Ne t'arrête pas.
- Je suis fatiguée.
- Je sais.
Vous voyez la différence
entre un chasseur et sa proie ?
Je vais te montrer qui est la proie.
Allez-y, suivez la rivière.
Allez jusqu'au village
et récupérez la voiture.
Ne verrouillez pas les portières.
- Attends-moi.
- On y est presque.
La voiture est là !
Fais le tour.
- Démarre !
- Où sont les clés ?
Ouvrez-moi, il arrive !
Ouvrez-moi.
Démarre, démarre !
Vous deviez laisser
les portes ouvertes.
Ne te retourne pas.
Accélère.
Vous avez eu un accident.
- Où est Maria ?
- Vous nous avez abandonnés.
L'ambulance arrive.
Où est Maria ?
- Où est James ?
- Où est Maria ?
Mesdames et Messieurs,
je vous présente Michelle Donovan.
Voici le Professeur John Howson.
Vous allez découvrir
ce qui s'est vraiment passé.
Nous étions partis
avec des objectifs différents.
Nous voulions tourner
un documentaire.
Ils voulaient changer les choses.
J'ai appris une chose
grâce à James, mon caméraman.
Il était mon ami.
Il a donné sa vie.
Peu importe si quelque chose
vous échappe.
Peu importe si vous êtes sceptique.
Ça n'a aucune importance.
Ça ne signifie pas
que ça n'existe pas.
Nous n'avons eu que peu de temps
pour récolter des preuves.
Nous allons devoir
retourner dans la forêt.